let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
good afternoon everybody Welcome to
let's talk the Tony Michaels podcast
episode number four
we got a lot to talk about today there's
a lot going on
it's all kind of focused in the United
States Senate
so I believe that's where the majority
of our show is going to concentrate
today
is the United States Senate hello
everybody out there welcome to let's
talk the Tony Michaels podcast episode
number four we're glad you joined us
today we're here every Wednesday at
three o'clock Central for Eastern so
join us live or if you can't catch it
live [ __ ] them you know just go watch it
record it go watch it recorded I've got
someone on the line here you guys knows
you've seen her in our shows it's Sam
hey Sam how are you number four this is
number number [ __ ] four
yay so Sam Sam's doing her usual mom
thing on Wednesday she picks up her boys
so she's in the car but it it searched
for good lighting it serves for good
life it's okay this is a this is kind of
brutal but back there okay well you know
it's it's all right it's all right we
wouldn't want to shoot you in the back
seat you definitely want to be in the
front seat so so so I see you got your
Royal shirt on but uh I want to talk to
you about some Kansas City news as
everybody might know there's this thing
coming up on Sunday
what what is this thing that's gonna
happen on Sunday going to the Super Bowl
okay
sir in the Super Bowl I know you and
your your husband Steve are very excited
right oh so big big cheese fans so I was
watching a uh clip I I've watched a few
things about the Super Bowl and I'm
gonna watch the Super Bowl this year
um of course but
I I watched it last year and I watched
it this year and uh last year was a good
Super Bowl you know it was pre-pandemic
now we're in in the pandemic this is the
first Super Bowl that we're having in a
pandemic so it'll be interesting but but
I did watch a clip of Tom Brady and
Patrick Mahomes kind of do the whole
sucky sucky thing back and forth you
know what I'm saying oh you're so good
no you're so good oh you're so good
you're so good no you're so good you're
the best quarterback no you're the best
quarter and they had on these these
white hoodies that were like all you
know had all the Super Bowl patches on
them and everything yeah so I watched a
little clip on that so but that that's
probably about the extent that I've
actually I've actually watched so far on
the Super Bowl but I and I'm sure I'm
sure like not only are you gonna be guys
going to be watching every single
pre-game thing everything but every post
game thing you'll have every post-game
shirt every post game hat
um and Andrea Andrea actually got a
Championship uh shirt two-time
Championship shirt so that's kind of
cool the division championship so yeah
so who's your money on
well of course
right you want the Chiefs to win but I'm
also married to the most negative
the biggest Chiefs fan that has the
biggest negative
opinion on the planet because he he's
like well we're going to lose we always
lose right so he's so he's so he's
setting himself up for this expectation
we're already preparing himself which is
I mean it might happen but we're hoping
that they win but yeah he's if they if
they don't get the the coin toss at the
beginning of the game he's already like
well we're done it's done Tom Brady's
already won he's already [ __ ] won
this Tom Brady you know the only the
only person to really beat Tom Brady is
is Eli Manning which is kind of pathetic
but I mean it happened so Patrick
Mahomes is a much better quarterback
than Eli Manning so uh he should be able
to hold his own he should I think I
think I think it'll be a good Super Bowl
and that's what's gonna count it's gonna
be a good Super Bowl it's gonna be fun
to watch this Super Bowl some Super
Bowls you watch and they're just they're
[ __ ] boring as [ __ ] like one team's
beating the holy hell out of the other
team and it's not even worth watching at
that point
so at least this will be a fun one to
watch
it's gonna be a good one I'm very
excited I'm ready to go and I've already
got my menu planned out and everything
oh you're you got the food done it's
yeah
all of it awesome speaking of food and
eating I hear you've been having this uh
this mouth thing going on with like a
tooth or something
my wisdom tooth is kicking my ass
hopefully getting rid of it in the next
month so what so you don't have it
actually scheduled yet to get this thing
pulled it's not scheduled but I got my
consult in a couple weeks and then when
they say oh okay well we probably need
to take that out I'm like [ __ ] yeah we
do
so so they're taking all four of them
though at the same time
we're just gonna take them all out call
it good and then I'm sure Steve is going
to record me after I wake up from the
surgery that will make a fantastic Tick
Tock it's gonna be great and if it is
good enough I you know because I don't
do a lot of Duets or stitches but I
might just do it down you might scooch
that or do like that I might have to I
might have to and uh get get you on the
page so well I'm glad I'm glad you're
here today and I'm glad we're here
because we're going to talk about the
United States Senate today we're going
to talk about what's going on all the
[ __ ] all the drama all the nonsense
all the legal stuff that's going on have
you heard about what's going on this
this just tons of crazy stuff the United
States Senate is the center of the
universe
you have no idea okay well do it teach
me stay on stay on and I'll I'll give
you the download of what
what all the issues are in the United
States Senate okay let's let's let's get
to thank you Sam thank you for joining
us
we'll see you next week after the Super
Bowl and we'll discuss who won okay
how's that all right I'll see you then
okay all right guys so
we're going to get to
the
United States Senate
there's a lot going on in the Senate
right now a lot of stuff uh we have not
not only do we have this huge uh riff
with Mitch McConnell and Marjorie Taylor
green happening but we also have
we also have the trial of Donald Trump
right around the corner of his
impeachment and the arguing back and
forth that the constitutionality uh
Donald Trump had lawyers he didn't have
lawyers now he has lawyers
they have an argument they don't have an
argument they can spell United States
and they can't spell United States
there's a lot of stuff going on all on
top of that we have Mitch McConnell and
Chuck Schumer trying to figure out the
rules of the Senate so that the
Democrats who have the majority in the
Senate can actually have the
chairmanships
uh the [ __ ] committees the thing that
you get when you are in the majority
so we have all that going on
uh we we also have at the same time in
the Senate we have them arguing and and
debating and going to pass a bill
um that is going to be the
coronavirus package the stimulus package
it's going to have minimum wage it's
going to have a stimulus uh uh check
1400 hours is the projection so we're
gonna have all those things happening
all at once in the United States Senate
so it's going to be the center of the
universe here this is where we're going
to live the next two or three weeks is
uh the Senate so I have several Clips I
want to play for you today
um and there are tick tocks that I did
and they're very relevant here of what's
going on and some of these things that
are happening in the Senate so we'll get
to playing some of those today and I'll
I'll make sure that we really dive deep
into some of those subjects uh as far as
what is happening but let's start off
with this riff that we had over the last
week between Mitch McConnell
Kevin McCarthy Marjorie Taylor green
and Donald Trump we also had some other
names thrown in here Lindsey Graham has
kind of given his two cents uh Marco
Rubio is chimed in
uh we've had we've had people even John
thune has given his opinion and we've
had Mitt Romney of course
so all these United States senators of
course again the Senate is the center of
the universe right now but I want to
play you a video I did a tick tock I did
on this Jewish space laser lady Marjorie
Taylor green and I want to talk about
her on the other side so let's show that
Jewish space lasers why are they Jewish
let's talk Mercury Taylor green this
[ __ ] Wackadoo is the gift that keeps
on giving understand why anyone wants to
get rid of this crazy [ __ ] Karen
she's gonna be entertainment for [ __ ]
years Replay that you watch on Monday
Night Football where the quarterback
gets his femur [ __ ] crushed that's
Marjorie Taylor green and you want to
watch it over and over and over and over
again Jesus [ __ ] Christ we're broke
as a society hey I'll just put this
queuing on Queen on the health and
science committee Jesus [ __ ] or we
have her out in front of the cameras the
worse off it's gonna be for the
Republicans and that's not a bad thing
folks as I always say when these Nazis
are digging their political Graves do
not take the [ __ ] shovel out of their
hand look at it this way when you were a
kid and your parents caught you smoking
a cigarette they made you smoke the
whole [ __ ] pack and you were sick for
days so much so you thought you were
gonna [ __ ] die maybe a lighter and a
pack of Q Anon 100 you Republicans and
get to smoking [ __ ] them
so there's a lot going on
in my Tick Tock there uh number one this
issue of Jewish space lasers
so
Mitch McConnell decides that because
this lady believes that there's uh
Jewish space lasers that started the
wildfires out in California that's just
a line way too far and too too far to
cross over
is this idea of Jewish space lasers
number one I'm not sure why the hell
they're Jewish in the first place I mean
I know why she's a racist bigot and
she's an anti-semite
and she's a white supremacist so she
doesn't like Jews
but but what in the hell I mean space
lasers is bad enough but then you gotta
throw in the anti-semitic Trope of of
Jewish on there and I don't I don't
really get why why it went there but
this lady believes that 911 was a was a
hoax it was a setup she doesn't believe
that the plane
uh actually hit the Pentagon she
believes it's I don't know I guess she
believes the the missile Theory or
something like that uh you know it's
Wackadoo stuff even that some of these
prominent school shootings uh um uh
Parkland and uh uh some of these other
school shootings are false Flags so it's
not that they didn't happen
it's just that the government actually
orchestrated this thing so that they
could take the Second Amendment rights
away from people which is really [ __ ]
weird
um that that would be someone's position
to think that this idea that oh well
we'll use this to scare the country to
change a policy position I mean if they
actually if that actually worked don't
you think they would do that on a much
wider scale and we would [ __ ] know
about it the same thing about uh the
shooting in in Las Vegas at the country
music concert she believes that's a
false flag uh you know this Alex Jones
Infowars type [ __ ] so she's way off
the map
way off the map uh she believes in the Q
Anon stuff uh full stop
all I mean she she basically says yeah
I'm a q i I listen to Q
and of course we find out this last week
that one of the guys who were was
masquerading around on the internet as Q
is uh some kind of [ __ ] weirdo
um you know of course that's what it was
going to be
but the Jewish space laser thing
that was just a step too far from Mitch
McConnell and he says these are loony
ideas but but then he goes as far as to
call her a cancer of the party
which then creates this back and forth
between Mitch McConnell and Marjorie
Taylor green
uh you know a tweet a tweeting war with
Marjorie Taylor green because you know
this lady loves attention that's what
this Q Anon stuff that's what this this
false flag [ __ ] that's what all this
stuff is is attention and the reason why
is because she wants to raise money off
this stuff and that's the reason why
Kevin McCarthy Donald Trump and these
Republicans aren't really trying to run
away from her I mean there are some who
want to retain their party the GOP they
want to retain that that that old type
party that they have
but there's not a lot of them running
too far away I mean you had John thune
you had Mitt Romney some of these
typical ones that you would think that
would run away from this uh yet some of
them playing Coy with it like Lindsey
Graham said I haven't really seen the
videos I haven't seen it I I don't know
what you're talking about and then uh
Tommy tuberville if it's raining outside
that guy can't even read the [ __ ]
news apparently
um but
but where this thing comes to a head is
Kevin McCarthy went down to Mar-A-Lago
to visit with Donald Trump
uh Kiss the Ring to basically show that
I'm still loyal don't worry even though
I said those bad things about you and I
set him on the floor that you know
somehow you were responsible for the
Insurrection don't believe any of that
that I said on the floor that's on the
official record because I'm still loyal
to you uh at the same time because
McCarthy's trying to get Marjorie Taylor
green to shut the [ __ ] up because he's
getting a lot of heat uh about her
committee appointments which it does
seem like that the Democrats are going
to take her committee appointments away
which is a is a whole nother story a
whole nother hour uh but it does seem
like they're going to take her committee
appointments away but Kevin McCarthy is
in a tough spot here because he's trying
to he's trying to sell his loyalty to
Donald Trump
and get him to believe that yeah I'm
still loyal don't worry you still got a
loyal minority leader in the house no
don't worry about it
I'm still your guy
don't torch me
don't do it
and then you have Marjorie Taylor green
who is who is uh lobbying Donald Trump
and to basically make sure that she gets
her Q Anon committee assignments
because that's that's ultimately you
know Donald Trump's game here is he
wants to play flamethrower inside the
house in the Senate
and that's where he's going to because
uh we have we have Mitch McConnell not
only taking the position against uh
Marjorie Taylor green which I believe is
the uh the way path forward for
Democrats to remove her from committee
assignments uh basically Mitch
McConnell's giving the green light that
that that the establishment is not going
to torch Democrats if they remove her
from committee assignments they are not
going to try to politically punish them
if they do that I believe that Mitch
McConnell really does want to pave the
way for Liz Cheney to be the minority
leader in the house I think he thinks
that's good for him and the party that
they want to retain uh and and all the
same while they're these Cuban honors
and these trumpers in the house are
trying to oust Liz Cheney they want her
out
as the conference chair Liz Cheney is
number three leadership in the house
um and Steve scalise who is second in
leadership is between
Kevin McCarthy and Liz Cheney going well
you know we should investigate and
figure out what the deal is with the Q
Anon but you know we can't demonize
these people either I mean he's you know
he's trying to play Both Sides here so
there's a lot going on and of course
Mitch McConnell uh is trying to hold
together his party because he wants to
be the leader of the party now that
Donald Trump is an ex-failed fat slop
president you know the the the mango
Jesus that he once was he's not anymore
um to most people in the party so you
know we have that going on in the Senate
now all the while
all the while
in the Senate we have
what's taking place of this
committee Arrangement the rules
organization
um and apparently they're going to vote
on it today I'm not I'm not quite sure
what time but they Chuck Schumer and
Mitch McConnell have come to an
agreement for the rules and how the
Senate is going to operate here as
you've noticed it's very strange the
last two weeks since Democrats have
actually taken over the Senate you've
seen uh Pete Buda judge Austin Lloyd
Janet Yellen a lot of these
Administration officials have gone
through the Senate confirmation process
but it's been Republicans leading these
committees
which is very awkward since the
Democrats have the majority in the
Senate
um and Chuck Schumer is the majority
leader it's still Republicans
sharing these committees which is really
awkward so when you have a 50 50 Senate
like that until you can come to an
agreement on rules you use the old rules
which the old rules are the Republicans
have the seat and the chairmanships on
those committees
so it's kind of [ __ ] weird
to have Chuck Schumer as the majority
leader but all these [ __ ] Republicans
chair in these committees and they're
they uh it is holding up some of these
confirmations
uh
Merrick Garland is being held up by
Lindsey Graham who is the head of the
Judiciary Committee but likely after
they get these rules in place
uh Lindsey Graham will no longer he'll
just be the ranking member on the
Republican side so he actually won't be
able to control that committee anymore
um he'll just have his say as a ranking
member so they're getting that fixed
today but that's been a lot of the the
awkward
um back and forth here of how that is
working so
and the other thing that they're uh
that's going on in the Senate right now
you've seen last week
there were 10 Senators Republican
Senators that signed on to a a reduction
in the coronavirus stimulus package they
wanted to scale back Joe Biden's plan uh
1.9 billion dollars is where Joe Biden
is at they wanted to be at um
600 uh
billion
and
so they're trying to scale back they
wanted him to scale back this plan so
they they come up with their own little
number
and decide oh well we'll let we'll see
if Joe Biden's gonna be bipartisan here
and they decide uh Joe Biden's gonna buy
this plan to show bipartisanship
well here's the [ __ ] thing
Joe Biden doesn't need you [ __ ]
he doesn't need you because he's gonna
use reconciliation they done said
they're going to use reconciliation so
they only need the 51 votes to get this
through and Joe manchin has already
given public commitment that yes he is
for the 1.9 billion dollar stimulus now
he is not he is not for the minimum wage
which we're going to talk about here in
a second but he is for this package and
he is for using reconciliation to do
this package and the reason why is
because Joe manchin does not want to get
caught in a boat where he has to vote
away
the filibuster because that would be the
way around it either reconciliation of
the filibuster and they voted yesterday
the house and the Senate have both voted
on this procedural measure
um to get this this package through uh
to use reconciliation to pass this
package and get it into law
but these 10 senators are invited to the
Oval Office by President Biden God damn
it feels so good to say that President
Joe Biden
damn it feels good to say that but they
get invited to the Oval Office by
President Biden
and they have a sit down for a couple
hours
um I believe what actually happened to
that meeting is this Joe Biden said look
this isn't a partisan thing and if you
want to make it a partisan then go ahead
go ahead and vote against vote against
the American people getting a 1400 check
go ahead and try that see how partisan
that issue ends up for you
see how see how you end up on that side
because Joe Biden knows he's gonna get
Republicans a few Republican votes on
this on this package I don't think
there's going to be many of these 10
Republicans that are going to be caught
not voting for the stimulus checks
um as you watched at the end of December
when they passed the 600 hour stimulus
checks and at the last minute Donald
Trump says no I want
our chicks and not not only did the
majority of American people say yeah
yeah but I mean [ __ ] if you're gonna
give out money let's do four or five
thousand dollar stimulus checks but it
wasn't just liberals and Democrats and
radical socialists that wanted the 2 000
checks it was Trump supporters that were
clamoring about the two thousand dollar
checks at that point
so I think I I feel that Joe Biden
thinks he's got the country behind this
1400 hours regardless if he passes it or
Trump passes it I mean worst case
scenario all he's got to do is convince
these trumpers and these Cuban Honors
that Donald Trump passed the 1400 and
here's your Trump check there you go I
just cashed it for you
because I mean you know these these
folks they they're not coupled to
reality so it's not going to be hard to
convince them otherwise but we also have
several different things built into this
package
um including the minimum wage and that
is the one thing that uh Joe manchin
from West Virginia is uh opposed to is
the 15 the raise of the 15 Dollar an
hour minimum wage
now I I did a video a tick tock and I
want to show it here
of the minimum weight about the minimum
wage and
um this stupid [ __ ] argument about
how well we can't raise a minimum wage
because McDonald's cheeseburgers will go
up to 50 bucks you know this is always
the stupid [ __ ] thing that people
start to argue about once we talk about
minimum wages how much cheeseburgers are
going to cost at a restaurant so let me
play that let me play that clip and then
we'll talk about it on the other side
fifty dollars for a hamburger let's talk
every time this [ __ ] country decides
to have a debate about Americans making
a living [ __ ] wage to do this stupid
[ __ ] thing where we guess how much
McDonald's hamburgers are gonna be you
dump number one who in the [ __ ] hell
orders a goddamn hamburger you get
cheese on that [ __ ] what is this
Russia for two quit [ __ ] complaining
about teenagers making 15 an hour
they're [ __ ] 50 cheeseburgers are
just as good as any other [ __ ] 50
cheeseburger see why are we so [ __ ]
concerned about McDonald's the [ __ ]
concern is the price of their goddamn
cheeseburgers maybe we shouldn't be
bitching about the people who make them
maybe about the CEO who makes 18 million
dollars a [ __ ] year stupid [ __ ]
argument about how minimum wage affects
the price of cheeseburgers is [ __ ]
dumb look at the better [ __ ] argument
would you please oh yeah [ __ ] them
so this idea that if we raise the
minimum wage which everyone has this
misconception about how the minimum wage
is going to work in the first place uh
but most people most people are thinking
oh my God if they if they pass this
minimum wage it's going to go from 725
to 15 an hour overnight and that is not
the truth that is not what is going to
happen they're going to gradually move
the minimum wage higher and higher over
a four or five year period depending on
how this bill lays out in the in the end
to work its way up now a lot of areas in
the country already have
um a wage the market wage is almost
fifteen dollars an hour anyways there's
a lot of places that in a lot of regions
where the minimum wage is either close
to or at 15 for the market wage which
means that when this minimum wage thing
goes into effect it's not even really
going to affect those areas so this r
argue about [ __ ] cheeseburgers is
dumb number one McDonald's or whoever
cannot sell a cheeseburger for any more
than what that cheeseburger is worth
okay and frankly McDonald's and any
other outfit whether it's Wendy's or
Applebee's or whoever is gonna sell
hamburgers
for the for the price that is gonna make
them the most profit
and that doesn't always mean it's going
to be the most expensive that's not what
it means I mean a lot of people fail to
remember in business models there's lost
leaders here I mean if you guys remember
the the McDonald's dollar menu you
really think when they had dollar
cheeseburgers on the McDonald's menu
that that that was the highest price
that they could actually charge for a
McDonald's cheeseburger at that time
hell to the no
that is not the thing that happened
they were trying to get your fat ass
through the drive-through and buying
dollar cheeseburgers and then maybe
you'll add on a large fry and a large
Coke and they'll make their profit there
so this idea somehow that uh uh the
price of Labor is going to directly
affect the price of hamburgers is
[ __ ] dumb and the other the other
problem with your little [ __ ] stupid
cheeseburger argument
is that McDonald's is pretty much across
the board the same price a Big Mac in in
an area that that has a higher minimum
wage and a state that has a higher
minimum wage than has a lower the price
of the Big Macs are not that different
it's the same thing it's the same price
and the reason why is it's the same
business model
again they're trying to make the most
profit on the price of that product
whatever the hell that is whether it's
higher lower whatever it would be but
they can't sell it for more than it's
worth because if they raise the price to
hamburgers to 15 per hamburger or what I
surmise is fifty dollars which is a a an
extreme exaggeration but that's the
point it's the [ __ ] point of the
video
is you're you're way over exaggerating
what the actual
[ __ ] point is
if you pay if they charged 15 or ten
dollars for a McDonald's cheeseburger
they would sell exactly zero of them
none they wouldn't sell any of those
[ __ ] and a hundred percent of
nothing is [ __ ] nothing
and if your argument is that labor and
and cost
of of profit and wages affects the price
of cheeseburgers then maybe we should
look to the CEO of McDonald's
this guy makes 18 million dollars a year
that's a lot of goddamn cheeseburgers in
and of itself but I think the thing that
I missed in the in the video in The Tick
Tock video
and uh not
it's because Tick Tock videos are 60
seconds so it's hard for me to add every
single little detail into that video
but here's the thing
if
if you look at where most of the
the pure profit goes
it's going to the franchise owners and
the argument always is oh well those
franchise owners are local business
owners they're local and they and and
they're local people yeah so the [ __ ]
what so are the goddamn people making
the hamburgers and frying the fries
and throwing the [ __ ] out the window and
collecting the money they're local
[ __ ] people too
and they participate in local economies
so what what the hell is your argument
and really if you look at it they most
of these franchise owners they're not
they're not local as in they own one
McDonald's in the neighborhood that they
live in
most of these owners own uh half dozen
or a dozen actual franchise locations
and that's where that's where the
majority of the profit's going to these
franchise owners uh not just the
McDonalds Corporation in and of itself
you have to remember that too so this
argument about [ __ ] cheeseburgers and
the price of cheeseburgers being
affected by minimum wage is [ __ ] dumb
and if you're gonna form an argument
against against minimum wage and it
going up to 15 an hour
and you know we can talk about inflation
and all that [ __ ] and get into the
facts
everyone always wants to argue that you
know charts and stats
but look here's the decency [ __ ]
argument
how about people who work 40 hours a
[ __ ] week
have enough [ __ ] money to feed their
[ __ ] families and have a living
goddamn wage and if you people out there
that think that people who flip Burgers
it's so [ __ ] easy they don't deserve
15 an hour well why don't you quit your
hard [ __ ] job when 15 an hour comes
and go try flipping burgers then if it's
so [ __ ] easy
so get off your [ __ ] high horses and
when you go through the drive-through
quit bitching and complaining about the
people helping you eat lunch
tell them thank you and hope that they
make a living [ __ ] wage for the work
that they're doing because they're not
all teenagers folks they're not [ __ ]
teenagers teenagers aren't all working
at McDonald's
that's another [ __ ] dumb argument too
but we ain't got enough time to get into
that [ __ ] we gotta get back to the
Senate here but my point was with the
minimum wage is Joe manchin thinks it's
a good idea even in West Virginia
and West Virginia it's a good idea to be
against a 15 minimum wage
Jesus [ __ ] Christ if he really has
his finger on the temperature in West
Virginia what in the [ __ ] hell is
going on with West Virginians that they
think that the minimum wage is going to
hurt them
you dumb [ __ ]
so I digress on that issue
so let's get back to the Senate
and some other things that are going on
uh so back to back to this idea the
minimum wage and the stimulus package
um this is going to move through and
they're going to move it in two
different ways they're going to move it
through the house and the Senate so they
can reconcile these bills as fast as
they can so that way they can get it on
Joe Biden's desk because I think the big
victory for Joe Biden the Democrats here
is going to be that they're going to get
the one point 1.9 uh bill that they
wanted
they're gonna get that bill uh and
they're gonna be able to run Victory
laps and see we got the bill we wanted
rather rather they liked it or not we
[ __ ] got it rather they we got rid of
the filiber Buster not we [ __ ] got it
and the Republicans know that this is
gonna happen
uh that that they're gonna have this
Victory and it's it's it's not going to
look good on Republicans in a few months
when Americans are still struggling
because we're still struggling to get
the vaccine out we're still struggling
to manufacture the vaccine and we're
still having a systemic problems through
with this coronavirus in our economy
so
uh they better get the [ __ ] their heads
out of their [ __ ] ass and get over
this head up ass syndrome and speaking
of head up ass syndrome you guys know
I've been using that phrase here lately
head up ass syndrome and I think that
explains a lot of this [ __ ] these
[ __ ] people around here they got
their head up their [ __ ] ass and they
need to pluck it out
uh one of those people uh is Rupert
Murdoch I did a video uh last week I
believe he did an interview with the New
York Times he's very concerned oh he's
super worried
super worried about woke people
and canceling cancel culture
he's got a lot of worries about it of
course you know he probably should worry
about it
because we're on to him and we've been
on to him for a long goddamn time
but I think a lot of moderates and
Republicans out there
who watch these idiots uh
just dump dump this big lie of election
fraud and all this Q Anon [ __ ] and
just garbage just [ __ ] trash ass
garbage and trotch these people out here
on TV over and over and over again to
lie and lie and lie I think finally
Beaver like this is this is nonsense and
that's enough we're not watching you
anymore and really he's losing he's
because he doesn't know what to do he
doesn't know who to cater to he's losing
a lot of his uh crazy viewers anyways
because they're going over to Aon and
Newsmax to get their fix over there you
know they gotta have their fix of of
[ __ ] so they gotta go over there did
you see
real quick before I get to this clip and
I wish I would have clipped this out so
we could show it did you see this
interview
on Newsmax of the my pillow Nazi you
know the my pillow guy
he gets on Newsmax
and they're trying to talk to him about
being canceled on Twitter because they
permanently banned his Twitter account
and then he decides it's a good [ __ ]
idea to go tweet on the My Pillow
account and they [ __ ] ban that
account too they're like you're done
[ __ ] we told you to stay off Twitter
you'd stay off our platform you mustache
Mussolini so they cancel him and they
have him on Newsmax to talk about how he
was canceled on Twitter
and he starts bringing up Dominion
voting machines and if you don't know
Ohan and Newsmax and Fox News are going
to be wrapped up in these multi-billion
dollar uh lawsuits these libel lawsuits
that that Dominion has against them
and there has to be some
some good cause for this and the reason
why is because if you watch this
interview you'll see that they are
absolutely [ __ ] terrified of these
lawsuits I mean scared out of their
[ __ ] minds I mean Rudy Giuliani is is
being sued for like a gazillion dollars
you know I think it's 1.3 billion is
what Dominion is that the lawsuit uh was
filed for uh they're gonna Sue Cindy
Powell uh Donald Trump they're trying to
get him to retain records uh of course
they're they're threatening to sue
Newsmax Aon Fox News for disseminating
this these big liable lies against them
and somehow they're you know they were
responsible for an election fraud that
doesn't [ __ ] exist uh and then
tearing down their company
but the my pillow Nazi is sitting there
and and the Newsmax host says hey hey
we're not talking about voting machines
there's no there's no [ __ ] evidence
there's no [ __ ] evidence that anyone
toyed with voting machines please stop
saying their name dominion and voting
machine stop saying those words we will
be sued
and uh of course it almost seems like
they turned down his mic Mike lindell's
mic because he's just talking he's
yapping just [ __ ] crazy crazy garbage
right into the microphone and finally
the host he has had enough of this [ __ ]
and he can't shut this guy up so he
tells the control room to turn him off
and he just stands up and walks off he
literally just stands up he's had enough
he just gets the [ __ ] out of there he's
not gonna be liable for this [ __ ] which
was absolutely fantastic little clip and
it just shows you how crazy these Q Anon
[ __ ] actually are and and and
how this this uh worship of make America
great again has totally [ __ ] uh uh
deluded these people's minds but uh it
goes back to this idea of cancer culture
and who's gonna get what and Rupert
Murdoch is a [ __ ] terrified of this
he's terrified of this now I think Fox
News will win out because Rupert Murdoch
has pretty [ __ ] Pockets here and it's
not like he's a novice at this game
this game of propaganda and lies I mean
but let me let me play this little clip
that I had uh this Tick Tock video that
I did we'll talk about it on the other
side are you awake yet let's talk it's
news corpse Rupert Murdoch tells the New
York Times that he's worried about the
super woke Orthodoxy he's [ __ ]
worried about him Rhonda you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you think he's finally realizing
that the lies in propaganda has just
went a bit too far we even went as far
as their [ __ ] host and they're sick
of fan guests to be bitching on air in
front of a camera about how they've lost
Twitter followers
what the [ __ ] do you think you are
social media teen influencers you dumb
[ __ ] tell you something when the
fascist propaganda arm in this country
is a little terrified of people knowing
the truth this is a good [ __ ] sign
Erica they know we know that they know
that their ideas [ __ ] suck [ __ ] them
and that's the beautiful point there at
the end that they know that we know that
they know that their ideas suck and that
where that's where it comes down to
folks I mean that's why that's why
Rupert Murdoch has been so successful at
Fox News is because they've known that
their policy ideas are [ __ ] horrible
and they know that their policy ideas do
not help the majority of people in this
country they don't
and that's why they have to sell lies
they have to sell propaganda they have
to spin this into uh you know they spend
it in a hundred different directions any
Direction they can at any point but
right now it's it's in the way of Maga
make America great again you know they
they they did the whole birther thing
while Obama was President and then uh
when when uh when Trump and Hillary ran
against each other was all about her
[ __ ] emails I mean Jesus Christ they
still talk about her [ __ ] emails on
Fox News
and it's been five goddamn years almost
now now it's complete
front to back
voter fraud
that didn't that doesn't exist
I mean this this is this is uh uh not
sustainable
in any kind of universe where the
majority of people are Tethered to
reality and that's the problem that
they're having because they're trying to
attract some of the people that are
Tethered to reality the people that have
no idea what reality is anymore they
don't even know what the truth is
anymore
and they're trying to attract both
crowds and they're running both of them
off all at the same time
and and this this uh this idea that
somehow people are super woke is all
[ __ ] too the super woke cancer
culture [ __ ] that is not what this is
that is not what this is this is
purebredic capitalism Rupert Murdoch you
dumb [ __ ] no one wants your product
and what I mean by that is the viewers
that you're trying to attract don't want
to hear facts on daytime Fox News they
don't want to hear hard facts they don't
want to hear hard news because hard news
does not fit their narrative
and at night when you have these these
morons like Sean Hannity Laura Ingram
and Tucker Carlson
that [ __ ] rube
when you have them at night just just
I mean absolutely
setting dumpster fires about election
fraud and uh how black lives matter and
antifa are terrorist groups when when we
have actual domestic terrorist groups
that are that are the people who are
watching their shows
and listening to what they're saying is
storming the capital because of it
be a [ __ ] break cancer culture my ass
my ass
and speaking of canceled culture
let's get on to the last subject here of
the United States Senate that we're
gonna see over the next few weeks
and that's the ultimate cancel
the impeachment trial of Donald J Trump
mango Jesus
so we're gonna get into that little
that little tidbit here soon and it's
already started up because you you've
seen that Donald Trump
at the behest of Lindsey Graham hired a
a team of serious lawyers one of them
was pretty prominent lawyer from South
Carolina Lindsey Graham's home state
and they had a team of five apparently
but this team of five was was cut off
pretty quick
and the reason why is because the
ex-president
Donald Trump the end twice impeached
ex-president Donald Trump once his
defense to be about voter fraud he wants
to continue and perpetuate these this
lie about voter fraud on the floor of
the United States Senate inside the
impeachment trial which is not a good
idea
it really is not a good idea to go and
lie on the senate floor it's not going
to work very well
and the reason why is because you're
going to get some of these Senators that
are not going to vote with Marjorie
Taylor green types if you get catch my
drift here
I mean why do you think that Democrats
are trying to make Marjorie Taylor green
the face of the party
is because they're gonna make [ __ ]
Republican senates
vote either for that type of thought and
that type of [ __ ] or reality
[ __ ] that's real facts
you're gonna have to decide you're gonna
have to make a [ __ ] real Choice here
and that's what it's going to come down
to
so these five lawyers
that were supposed to defend Donald
Trump did not think it was a good idea
to use the argument uh this Q Anon
argument
because that's what was going to happen
here folks that this Q Anon [ __ ] was
gonna leak into this trial
so they all quit they tell him to go
[ __ ] himself
which is basically what happens in
Donald Trump's life because he's not a
serious person
I mean that's why we have these Marjorie
Taylor greens and Lauren boberts and mo
Brooks these are not serious [ __ ]
people
and the reason why we have these people
in the house and some of them in the
Senate is because Donald Trump a a not
so serious person at all became the
president United States so it was easy
for for councilmen and state legislators
and governors and and Congress people
and Senators to become
[ __ ] elected officials when they're
not so [ __ ] serious as well
and that's a problem that we have
is it's not a serious deal we're not
this is these people are not serious
[ __ ] people
so their idea was Trump's idea is to
have the argument of election fraud on
the senate floor as a defense
so they all walk out on him tell him to
[ __ ] off
and he has to gather up a new [ __ ]
legal team so he he searches around in
dumpsters all over uh the United States
and finds two two
lawyers that are willing to go along
with this [ __ ] narrative
this narrative that that election fraud
was the thing that that caused all of
this if there was an election fraud
while there wouldn't have been planning
of an insurrection
and if there wasn't planning of an
Insurrection well the president can't
really incite something that's already
planned
whatever he was part of the planning
I don't think they've done the math on
this of what what is actually going to
transpire because he's already got a
handful of Republicans that are going to
vote to convict him I'm almost sure of
that
Rod Portman has already said he's not
going to rerun so that makes him safe to
vote however he wants we know that Mitt
Romney what choice Mitt Romney's gonna
make here he already made the choice
once he won't he won't have beef doing
it again Mitt Romney safe in Utah uh I
believe Lisa murkowski and Susan Collins
are going to be the next on that
chopping block
um if they do make the argument on the
floor if these Knuckleheads that he's
got
and I'll I'll talk about these two
Knuckleheads here in a second but if
these two Knuckleheads that he's got
these two lawyers that he's got
if if they do make this this election
fraud argument how it was stolen away
and uh dead people voted and all this
chewing on [ __ ] because that's what
this [ __ ] is is Q Anon [ __ ] this
election fraud stuff it does not
disseminate against any kind of uh from
any kind of evidence
it comes from these these [ __ ]
internet mobs of Maga people and these Q
Anon morons that's where all this shit's
coming from
so they're going to make these Q Anon
arguments on the floor of the Senate and
I believe that's gonna put uh
Pat Toomey a Pennsylvania in a position
to vote against him as well and the
reason why is because Pat Toomey has
already said look there is no election
fraud in Pennsylvania
full stop period and if they make that
argument that's a good enough argument
for him to vote against him and Mitch
McConnell has not even committed to to
vote to convict or not to convict Donald
Trump here which it is obvious where
Mitch McConnell stands at this point
he does not want Trump in the Republican
Party
I mean that's that's what he's doing
when he when he says Marjorie Taylor
green is a cancer in the party
he's wanting
to surgically remove these Q Anon people
from the Republican party I think that's
the only way they keep it alive
I mean it's totally fractured here
and the fracture is between what is
reality and what is not
so if we have that list of senators I
mean you're possibly possibly going to
have
um at least which which will be pretty
easy if they make the argument
of
of of going
with the election fraud
argument
that you're gonna have four or five
maybe even six senators
that are going to be on the page voting
to convict Donald Trump now that is not
enough to convict him
um
but
depending on the arguments that these
boneheads make it may just push a few
others
um and then and that will create even
more cracks and a bigger fault line in
the Republican Party
uh which the main vote here is the vote
to make sure that he can never run for
office again which they do not need a
two-thirds majority for that vote they
just need an up or down vote for that
son of a [ __ ]
um and I believe I believe that that's
the vote where they're going to handicap
him here and that's that's where these Q
Anon people are going to be pissed off
and that's where Mitch McConnell is
gonna is gonna use his Sledgehammer he's
gonna use to take over the party again
and be the party leader the national
party leader here but we'll see we'll
find out how this trial plays out
because we'll have to see what these
[ __ ]
um lawyers that he's got what kind of
arguments they actually [ __ ] make
on the senate floor
now these two morons one of them
oh one of them is Roger Stone's lawyer
you remember Roger Stone don't you
another [ __ ] whack-a-doo
another Trump trump Wackadoo Roger Stone
so this lawyer is the one that defended
Roger Stone in his federal trial that he
lost
he lost that federal trial he was
convicted on those charges
uh the only reason why I didn't go to
prison is because Donald Trump is butt
buddy
gave him a pardon
which I think he could come back and
bite him but that's a whole nother
podcast in and of itself
but this lawyer defended Roger Stone
he also apparently is one of the last
people
uh of Jeffrey Epstein's legal team to
meet with him and talk with him
before he he died in a Federal Detention
Center
so we have that little that little
connection there with Jeffrey Epstein
which
is golden you think Donald Trump would
stay away from anything Jeffrey Epstein
with Donald Trump's history with Epstein
and going on Howard Stern's radio show
and talking about how he likes to walk
in on young girls at beauty pageants you
know because he can do that type of
thing people forget about that but that
is a real [ __ ] thing
but this other attorney
you know speaking of rape
and women and me too
this other attorney was apparently a D.A
in in in in field in Pennsylvania
when they were trying to bring charges
against Bill Cosby and this guy was
against it
so we got that little tidbit there too
so I'm sure these two these two clowns
are just gonna make it for a great
season finale of the
dumpster fire Trump reality TV show here
because that's really what this trial is
folks
It's the final episode
the season finale
of the reality show dumpster fire
Trump TV show
that's what this is gonna be
because we lost we lost the last few
pages in this book
Jack Dorsey
weeks ago
strip Donald Trump have the ability to
tweet
and it was almost like it was almost
like
you were reading a really good book that
was about just
uh just a really good book
about war and people dying
and heartache
and you just couldn't put the book down
and you get to the back of the book
and the last [ __ ] three pages was
ripped out of that [ __ ] book we
didn't get to see what happened
because we had a direct line into what
this [ __ ] thought almost in any given
moment most the time when he was
probably on the [ __ ] or watching Fox
News
but we had a direct line and this this
shit-eating moron's brain besides that
last that last couple weeks
and up until now we haven't really known
uh what Donald Trump is affected by and
I think the only reason why Donald Trump
hasn't went on another platform is uh
you know he's he's got a dick complex
with Barack Obama Barack Obama has a
huge following on Twitter
I think he's got one of the biggest five
I think if not the biggest following on
Twitter and he's he's really you know he
gets in a in a as a dick complex with
with uh Barack Obama that Barack Obama's
on Twitter and and he's got more
followers than him so I think that's why
he ultimately wants to be on Twitter and
he won't go on another platform
but uh this trial is definitely going to
be the season finale
um it's going to be it's going to make
huge news and anyone who thinks Donald
Trump is going to be out of the news now
that he's not the president
is completely wrong because we're get
we're about to get
just our daily dose of of trump [ __ ]
here
uh and it's all going to come out of the
Senate again that's why the Senate is
going to be the center of the universe
because not only are we going to have
this trial we're going to have them
doing uh passing the stimulus package
with the uh through reconciliation
um we also are going to see in the next
week how these rules are going to play
out as the Democrats take over these
committees
and uh but once they they
wield the power of this that they truly
will the power of the Senate when they
have the chairmans of these committees
um it's going to be very apparent
how hard they're going to swing this
sword
we're also going to watch this feud
between the Mitch McConnells and Mitt
Romney's and John thunes of this world
against the Kevin McCarthy's and the
Donald Trumps are yeah Kevin McCarthy
Donald Trump's and Marjorie Taylor
greens
so we're gonna watch this all play out
in the Senate
and that's where it's gonna be and it's
gonna be fantastic what a fantastic show
it's gonna be so stay tuned because I'm
sure next week when we come back on the
podcast live at three o'clock on
Wednesday three o'clock Central four
o'clock Eastern we will be talking about
all kinds of great stuff that has
happened in the Senate I believe we will
also be discussing uh what kind of
committee assignments Marjorie Taylor
green does or doesn't have next week
so stay tuned next week come back and
see us and I'm glad you were here today
I'm glad you joined us on let's talk the
Tony Michaels podcast
and next week we'll have just as much
fun
and you know what
if no one watches no one pays attention
well
[ __ ]
um you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them